you're very good at working you know if
figuring out how can I take this
situation and use it to drive people
towards the world of Bert Kreischer
might or what I'm doing you have had
some missteps in yourself promotion
hardcore hardcore I perform shirtless
obviously if you don't know and one of
the things I've been like my dream was
to make a shirt of me shirtless and then
put you know the tour bodyshots world
tour on the front sell the shirt I can
see you nodding right now it's a home
run right you want one you want one yeah
until you actually see what they did
here we put it all real quick it looks
like you've got plastic surgery in South
America the nipples are under the arms
like he was like oh just put the nipples
there anywhere bro and then you're like
yeah this is actually this is exactly
where my nipples are on my body I got
I'm taking a bath any shirts I have like
700 in my garage so no ones these are
not moving they're like an idiot I put
tour dates on the back and so now
they're like kind of branded I'm not
going back to those cities in that
Oregon order again so I just have a ton
so if you guys want one I have 700 in my
truck so I should be able to get over
everybody that's guess what you we have
enough for everybody plus one I will not
be keeping this is it great to work out
in you know I'm just happy anyone tuning
in late to the show tuning in right now
let's say they're your nipples yeah
these are urine and keep the stay on the
chart for God's sake it doesn't even
look like me like
you gotta put this back on no one can
hear you take this off and just clip
this to your chest here yeah there yeah
that's good see like this is a
proportionate do these look alike you
know we finally did we finally invented
porn no one will watch cable access from
the late 70s and and II remember like
eighties they were talking bird show but
have guys that looked like us naked just
sitting around and it was it was Andy
has some tattoos Hubert rats yeah I got
seriously into some weird [ __ ] no I
hated this when I first put it on and
you know I'm actually kind of liking it
i dude I love being shirtless it's like
my favorite thing in the world but I
grew up in Florida floor is weird I knew
two kids growing up without tongues
that's Florida for you wait a minute
what they were did they lose the tongue
in an accident they didn't tell us they
were just kind of I mean I think the
reason they didn't tell you is because
they don't have Tom hate wearing shirts
well at least you're happy oh there's a
lot of perimenopausal women right now
going back it up five seconds hello
he looks like he comes with a life
insurance plan huh we have a new chore
and the tickets are on sale tomorrow is
that clear Morrow pre-sale starts at
10:00 a.m. the birdie boy US tour starts
go to / / / calm use the promo code
birdie boy and get him before general
sale starts this Friday the brand names
in my head Conan I know I was gonna I
was gonna say all that and now I'm not
going to you just made my life a lot
easier
you're paying for the steam cleaning of
this chair our next guest Dame Judi
Dench oh my lord what is this what
someone from Florida out
[Laughter]